you know the bummer in reviewing
something like Firefly is the
possibility that I might not completely
and totally convey how necessary it is
for you to watch this show other than
that pretty excited to talk about it so
shiny
let's review Firefly finally Firefly so
Firefly was created by Joss Whedon over
10 years ago it aired on Fox and it was
shortly cancelled for all intents and
purposes it was dead on arrival and I
will talk about all of that in more
detail but for right now let's
illustrate what Firefly in Firefly takes
place 500 years in the future but it's
not a sci-fi it's a Western and in the
future you have the Alliance which is
pretty much the government of America
and China have fused together to form
these super government the Alliance the
current solar system that you and I live
in right now is all burned out earth is
just it can't sustain our numbers so
everyone migrated to another solar
system with dozens of planets and
hundreds of moons they were all
terraformed and the inner planets are
all civilized in high-tech and the
Alliance really controls those but then
you have the outer rim planets and moons
which more or less the show revolves
around they look and feel more Western
and with the expansion of this
government they were like yeah we're
gonna go ahead and control everything
the outer rim planets are like we don't
want your control so now we have a civil
war the main star of the show Firefly
Malcolm Reynolds played by Nathan
Fillion fought in that war and in a
bizarre turn of events you know how
usually and things like this is like oh
they fought in the rebellion in the
rebellion one not this time the
rebellion got stomped Malcolm Reynolds
and the other Browncoats fighting for
independence lost the war thus the
Alliance maintains control of all the
planets a few years later we now have
the show Firefly in which Malcolm
Reynolds is like I have my ship serenity
which is the Firefly class ship he's a
smuggler he does runs he does transport
along with the greatest ensemble crew
put together this side of Final Fantasy
6 we now have our show Firefly and when
I say the show is a Western I really
mean it it does not feel like a sci-fi
everything about it should on paper
you're like oh it's a guy flies around a
spaceship at another solar system he's a
smuggler like Han Solo on the Millennium
Falcon and he has his crew and the
planetary government's going after him
and it just it sounds sci-fi but it's
not it's the most realistically feeling
and grounded show that's ever taking
place in the future imagine in the 50s
they made a show where they had
smartphones and tablets and computers
digital cameras that would seem like
by it's just an accurate representation
of what the future would be that's what
Firefly feels like he just feels like a
very realistic take of what probably
will be 500 years from now I mean I like
Star Trek but I don't think the features
actually going to be like Star Trek what
if I had to put my chips on it I'd be
like fireflies are pretty good bad the
other thing I love about the show there
are no aliens or just a lot of people
spread across a lot of planets and moons
because there are a lot of people now
that's all you deal with the people the
most alien thing in the entire show are
these things called Reavers which you
don't actually see in the show Firefly
you run across the aftermath of a river
attack you run across a river ship in
the show you don't know where they come
from you don't know who they are but you
do know that they're ravenously violent
cannibal people it's like imagine the
zombies and Dawn of the Dead had the
wits about them to run a ship and they
rape you to death and where your skin is
trophies that those are rivers I guess
but again nothing says that they're
aliens you don't know where they come
from yet in the show being created to
look and feel like a Western they used
lenses that give lens flares like not JJ
Abrams lens flares but you know settle
lens flares there's a lot of zooming
going on when something zooms it's out
of focus for a second it goes into focus
you see that a lot of times in westerns
but nowadays you're like oh that's just
cheesy but the cheesy factor actually
works for the show when you have a cult
hit with cheese factor dude you have
gold Avenue is going to be a cult hit
but it is a cult hit another thing that
adds to the realism of the show and
makes it feel like a Western more than a
sci-fi is the fact that not only do they
use horses which they do they also use
powder weapons guns bullets no lasers
lasers do exist in this world but they
exist in the core planet so you don't
really see a lot of them common people
which is 99% of the people in this verse
they use powdered weapons kind of like
concept cars concept cars like this they
exist in our world today we're all
intensive purposes people don't drive
those laser technology does exist but
it's not what common folks use you see
like two laser guns in the entire show
just everything in the show Firefly
worked perfectly just very few times
I'll ever say that this was flawless
but Firefly was flawless we'll take the
crew I'm gonna break the crew down for
you first of all Malcolm Reynolds slayed
by Nathan Fillion the guy is a nerd icon
if you have a nerdy bone in your body
you know who Nathan Fillion is in short
he is the man this is the classic case
of the character was written one way but
the actor actually brought enough of him
into the character to make him a
complete person the character of
Malcolm Reynolds was written to be
really bitter and damaged and he does
have those things going for him he lost
a war to the government in a world where
people love damaged characters Malcolm
Reynolds has lost all hope in the Battle
of serenity Valley at the very beginning
of the show
seeing Malcolm Reynolds pull out across
and he kisses it and puts it under a
shirt he goes to war and they lose now a
few years later the guy has lost all of
his faith he's just damaged he's like no
no God just my ship and let's go about
our business he has no need to fight the
war he doesn't want to fight the
Alliance he just wants to go his way but
nathan fillion brought to the character
of Malcolm Reynolds was a likability his
sense of humor is sarcasm his humanity
if anyone else had played Malcolm
Reynolds I really don't think it would
have worked out how it worked out
Malcolm Reynolds would have been this
closed-off character with his walls up
but in Nathan Fillion bringing a sense
of humor and a warmth to him he always
told Joss Whedon he's like I am NOT this
person I'm not that bitter he turned him
into a character who has his balls up in
his bitterness because he does have a
heart of gold underneath a heart of gold
that was crushed and stomped out by his
crushing defeat on the Battle of
serenity Valley at the hands of the
government Malcolm Reynolds is pretty
much imagine Nathan Drake from the
Uncharted series but he'd lost a war so
now he's just a little more better and
in going his way he is a smuggler
I can't illustrate the whole Han Solo in
the Millennium Falcon vibe enough
Malcolm Reynolds second in command is
Zoe Zoe was one of his war buddies she's
a complete badass but I love about her
and mal they both would shoot first
Greedo would stand no chance their
sarcasm bounces off each other so they
work well together
I guess Zoe was created as a fail-safe
they're like all right if nathan fillion
doesn't work for the show we need to
know that the second command can step up
and actually lead the show I don't know
how we live in a world where it was ever
a thought that Nathan Fillion and
Malcolm Reynolds that that whole thing
wouldn't work I know you got to have
your contingency plan they never had to
go through with it but so E is a badass
she is married to watch the pilot wash
is more or less the comic relief in a
show like Firefly that is written so
perfectly among all these characters
where their dialogue bounces off of each
other brilliantly in ingenious form you
could say that everybody is the comic
relief because everybody has comedic
moments without the show being a comedy
in remaining a drama but wash is the
comic relief he's the exact opposite of
Zoe so he's a warrior he is not he's
funny she's not a comedian he never
fought in the war he doesn't want to
fight a war but he's a badass pilot we
got Shepherd book Shepherd book is the
preacher on the ship at first mouths
like really
but he rolls with it you can tell they
mutually respect each other he's like
the Jiminy Cricket the conscience
they're all smugglers they're doing
their smuggler thing and you have a
preacher on board he is going to be the
voice of reason but that dude has a
secret I mean naturally Shepherd book
wasn't always a shepherd he wasn't
always a preacher more than a couple
times you get the feeling this guy was
tied to the Alliance somehow and this
guy knows a lot about their operation
how deep does that go I guess we'll find
out because the show won't get canceled
of wait it did I guess they explained
Shepherd book story in a graphic novel
but I wanted to see it on screen
whatever the case I loved characters
like Shepherd book I loved characters
with a secret and I guess a little side
note here the plan was for everyone to
have a secret if the show had gone on
everyone would have a secret that would
come to the surface but a the show got
cancelled so we didn't know that then we
have Jane Jane is the Merc he is the
mercenary you pay the guy the guy will
do anything the other guy pays the guy
more than you paid him he will probably
do anything the other guy wants which
doesn't really bode well for you first
run through the show Jane was like my
least favorite character because I was
like all right you're just a mercenary
how deep can they be when you watch the
show a couple times you're like no
Jane's amazing and he has Vera hey
everyone has something they love mal has
his ship he named his serenity Jane can
have his gun Vera then we have the
companion Inara this is when we start to
see the culture of the future
Inara is actually the credible person on
the crew she has an ambassador status
people like oh you have a companion on
board you are a legit transport you're
not smugglers what's a companion we'll
choose a [ __ ] registered by the guild
and everything that's right prostitution
is legal in the future it's probably why
we all love Firefly she has her tension
with mal you can tell they have a thing
between each other but of course they
don't act on it because they're both
stubborn people and the show was
cancelled I can't say that enough I
can't stress that enough as a negative
which brings us to Kaylee now Kaylee's
the engineer she's like the genius
engineer of serenity a firefly-class
ship which is what serenity is is not
the most prestigious class Smuggler's
love them because they're good at
smuggling things but really it's a piece
of [ __ ] she keeps the thing flying she
knows how to work out all the Kings and
what's funny about this Jewel Staite was
told that she would have to gain 20
pounds to play Kaylee because joss
whedon wanted people who were real like
we can't have everyone look like models
we already have Inara the engineers not
going to look all just hot it out I have
to stress she's still hot in that you
know cute hot chick kind of way and now
we have the Tams
in Tammuz a doctor really prestigious
doctor who brings a creative cargo on
board you don't really know what it is
you find out it's his sister River this
guy has given up his entire fortune to
find his sister because his sister was
being held in a facility of the
government you don't really specifically
know what the Alliance did to rivers
brain all you know is they messed her up
now the Alliance is coming after her
with a vengeance Simon and River are
wanted people now they're on mouths ship
and mouths like great really you brought
your drama into my home which also shows
the depth of mouths character because as
much as he wants to come across as
hardened and damaged and doesn't care
about people he doesn't leave them he
doesn't drop them off on a port or
anything like that he wants to one more
than a couple of occasions but he
doesn't but rivers the key to the entire
show as much as the show revolves around
the entire crew everyone is relevant you
get the feeling that River is the key
piece of the entire puzzle if they solve
her problem that would be like beating
the last boss of a game the game is over
because you win but her brains all
messed up and she speaks in riddles and
doesn't really understand what's going
on you can tell she's self-aware of the
fact that she's messed up but there's
this one awesome scene in this one
episode where she's going around and she
finds a stick on the ground and she
picks up the stick and she's just
looking at it and to her it's just a
stick and then it goes to what everyone
else sees and they're all like river put
it down put it down it goes to her again
and she's holding a gun and you can tell
she's just confused even the supporting
characters within episodes are great you
have Safran and are mrs. Reynolds which
again that episode is one of those
episodes that illustrates that the show
is a drama which can be funny but not
funny in that slapstick kind of way it's
just funny and good comedic timing and
Safran is played by christina hendricks
and that's just not a bad world we live
in however when the show wants to be
creepy and uncomfortable it is creepy
and uncomfortable can you think of a
more uncomfortable conversation than the
conversation that takes place in firefly
between early and Kayleen no you cannot
neither can i early as a bounty hunter
who shows up in one of the episodes
obviously contracted by the alliance to
find River Tam and bring her back to
them he's talking to Kahlan mid-sentence
he just interrupts Kaylee and he's like
never been raped and you're like why do
and of course you got to talk about the
soundtrack in the musical score the
music and Firefly is fantastic it's
Western twang but you hear Asian
inspiration and they're also like a
bunch of cultures just went splat made
tract that works just so unique in
genius it changes how you hear western
twang in music you hear you're like oh
yeah it reminds me a Firefly now there's
this one scene where there's a funeral
and I guess the composer of the show
they had all learned that the show is
getting cancelled at that time so the
music he wrote for the funeral scene is
actually his lament for the show you
watch it and you hear it and just makes
you cry and the title music I mean you
listen to the lyrics take my love take
my land take me where I cannot stand I
don't care I'm still free you can't take
this guy from me this goes on from there
and you're like that's Malcolm Reynolds
the intro song itself perfectly
illustrates where Malcolm Reynolds is
coming from I got the soundtrack I
listened to it and I'm always happy when
I do I can go on and on about the
dialogue and how it works well and how
characters bounce off of each other and
it's all perfection but what gives it
the extra mile what makes it feel real
and enjoyable to watch is the fact that
the actors work well together you know
when you have a couple of actors they
don't like each other and that
translates on screen it makes it
uncomfortable to watch well then the
opposite also applies when you have
actors that all love each other and feel
like a family when you watch that that
will come through and it'll be enjoyable
to watch as well Firefly was everyone on
this show just loved each other nobody
ever went to work no one on the
production of this show ever thought to
themselves oh I gotta go to work today
they all went to a set and they all hung
out as a family that really translates
on screen big time it's easy to see it's
right in front of your face and by that
what Fox did was they did not just
cancel the show they broke up a family
no other way to say it than that this is
14 episodes of fantastic entertainment
when I watch the show I'm always like
okay what's the episode that I would cut
you know you're looking for that episode
you're like that's the episodic episode
and I can't ever find it if I can think
of one it's the Jane town one the one
where they go to this mud town this is
piece of [ __ ] town but everyone there
thinks Jane is a folk hero and watching
it I'm always like okay this is
enjoyable but if this episode was not in
the show would it be affected I'm always
like probably not then by the end of
that episode I'm like nope that's
important character development for Jane
we need that episode in this show
Firefly blends the best elements of
character development drama comedic
timing relevance relatability just
everything is in this 14 episode package
that never should have been cancelled
and we will never know why we'll never
know why it was canceled I have no good
reason
everything about Firefly is definitively
awesome tacular
is the very definition of Awesome
tacular if ever there was one
the show is dead on arrival from the
get-go though honestly Fox was like well
we don't like the pilot episode because
it's a two-hour drama which absolutely
establishes the characters and what
they're fighting for but no air the
second episode first and after that
we'll just air it all out of order in
three episodes won't actually ever air
and then it's cancelled because it was
on Friday night who why it's just
injustice is what it is you can tell
Joss Whedon was like for all intensive
purposes this would be my masterpiece
and usually when someone makes their
masterpiece it's like oh that person has
a shot and the masterpiece flourishes
because they did it at the time that
they could do it we're biding their time
they got their budget never had the
production now they can do their
masterpiece Joss Whedon did that it was
like oh hey your masterpiece is cut off
I have never ever ever seen any form of
entertainment that has characters that
work this well together that are this
likable with the main character who's
just everything you wanted to be as a
kid embarking on his quest for what he
has to look forward to now which is his
love story between him and his ship and
his ship as every pirate has said is
freedom it's all gold and it was cut
down before it's time if you haven't
seen Firefly you can buy the entire
series on blu-ray for less than 20 bucks
I strongly strongly urge you to do that
watch the show after that you'll end up
watching the movie serenity he did get a
shot to conclude his story in the form
of the movie serenity that wraps up the
Firefly story that is a different review
for another time I will review serenity
separately from this video personally
what I would love to see alright let's
look at it realistically the cast of
Firefly they're older now they're 10
years older they look it so it'd be
really hard to return to the world of
Firefly you want Nathan Fillion to be
Malcolm Reynolds Jewel Staite to be
Kaylee Alan Tudyk to be washing you look
cetera et cetera but what I think would
be a smart thing to do to get telltale
games the one who made the Walking Dead
video game that was so awesome get them
to do chapters of Firefly you imagine
that five chapters all released like The
Walking Dead was new dialogue new
adventures have the actress play the
voices of their characters we could have
the continuing chapters of Firefly it'd
be badass that's just in my hopeful
world of something that might not ever
happen but I think should so have you
seen Firefly if you haven't watch it and
then come back to answer the question
what is your favorite episode of Firefly
whatever it is comment below that mean
my favorite episodes probably out of gas
and had the suspense and had the drama
it had the backstory I like the way it's
edited just everything worked in that
episode it shows how the crew became the
crew I'm glad we got to see that before
the show got the axe I could honestly
watch out of gas every day of my life I
could watch it next time someone stops
me in the streets in Vegas and it's like
do you go to church I'll be like well I
watched out of gas today so yes and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more